[Musique]
monsieur l'ambassadeur de la République
islamique d'Iran Mohamad Amin
nejjad bonsoir bonsoir monsieur nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle surview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succ
euh je suis Mohamed Amin nejjat je suis
l'ambassadeur de la République islamique
d'Iran à Paris
et je fais ma fonction ici il y a 10
mois et j'espère pouvoir contribuer à à
la l'amélioration de l'entente entre nos
deux pays nos de peuples on est très
content de vous recevoir ce soir on va
parler tout un tas de sujets on va
parler de géopolitique de finances
d'économie de tout un t de choses qui se
passent à l'heure actuelle dans le
monde pour briser la glace qu'est-ce que
vous faisiez avant qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez de la France qu'est-ce que
vous avez goûté de la
France
euh pour moi la France était un pays que
j'ai eu l'occasion de de connaître quand
j'étais j'ai commencé à être un
étudiant c'est FO j'ai commencé à appris
la langue française
et j'ai pu
avoir des des occasions de connaître à
travers les
différents livres
euh la civilisation française et la
culture française donc voilà
qui que maintenant plus
de 40 ans que je pratique un peu le
français peti petite et puis voilà je
suis là ici chez vous comme on dit je
t'aime maman en
farci qu'est-ce que vous faisiez avant
d'être
ambassadeur en fait j'étais en poste
comme ambassadeur dans trois pays
ou bien qure avec une très
courte durée au
nigère mais j'étais ambassadeur en Côte
d'Ivoire j'étais en ambassadeur en
Zimbabwe et puis voilà je suis
l'ambassadeur d'Iran ici avant j'étais
comme un Diplomat de
carrière je faisais comme le la jooint
de l'ambassadeur en Belgique et pour
l'Union européenne et le Luxembourg et
puis en avant avant ça j'étais Diplômate
aussi à
Paris et puis bon une une moitié de ma
carrière j'étais en poste à la centrale
à
Terran qu'est-ce que faisait maman
qu'est-ce que faisait papa
euh ma mère
était une femme de
ménage qui s'est consacré à nous
une une
famille nombreuse si vous voulez et mon
père était d'une d'un
employé de
l'état de de moyenne classe si vous
voulez et puis on s'est agrandi dans un
milieu euh
complètement familial et intégre
voilà c'est tout vous avez des grands
frères des grandes sœurs oui ou oui j'ai
j'ai j'ai deux grands sœurs mais je suis
le grand l'aîné garçon l'aîné de de la
famille et puis j'ai aussi de de frères
qui sont plus jeun que moi et une sœur
aussi donc parmi eux quelques-uns ont
déjà mariés sont déjà mariés mais il y
en a deux qui non sont pas acccord Mar
on commence par la géopolitique mais
bien sûr comme vous voulez ouais alors
d'abord je tiens à féliciter votre staff
technique qui a respecté sa parole et
vous avez respecté votre parole on a
proposer la même interview à l'ambassade
d'Israël on attend encore une réponse
vous savez qu'on aime bien être
équilibré écouter tout les points de vue
la voix de la France doit écouter tous
les points de vue les oreilles de la
France c'est important
géopolitique tout se passe bien c'est
très tendu sur une échelle de 0 à 100 en
terme de risque on est à combien selon
vous bon c'est vous savez sur la scène
internationale il y a toujours des défis
parfois plus grands
ou plus
important parfois moins
important pour
nous la République islamique
tyran nous nous avons heureusement ou
malheureusement nous avons heuré à des
situations assez difficiles et des
épreuves assez
important dans la
vie
contemporaine de notre peuple et nous
avons essayé tant que nous
puissions relever Cees défis
et voilà après 47 ans on est là et on
espère que pour les autres peuples les
autres nations la vie soit plus paisible
plus aisé et plus
prospère mais tout le monde sait que le
souhait c'est une chose mais la réalité
c'est
autre nous nous essayons de
peser comme un pays dans un
environnement assez agité mais très
important
de de faire un levier d'équilibre et de
la
stabilité et de montrer qu'on peut vivre
ensemble et partager le bonheur ensemble
et permettre à ceux à celles dans
les pays du monde différentes parties du
monde que ce soit en Afrique ou en
Amérique ou en
Asie d'avoir l'occasion de se de
se de se développer si vous voulez et
vraiment d'être en mesure et en
position de goûter la la le le plaisir
de développement le plaisir de de
d'avoir une identité une une une fierté
comme un être humain
donc voilà je crois je crois que les
pays qui sont nombreux qui cherche
vraiment
cette cette situation cette
euh
objective et avec et ensemble on peut on
peut vraiment sur monter tous les
difficultés et on peut mettre en en
ordre euh ce qui est vraiment ce qui ne
veut pas accepter la réalité et la
dignité du peuple et des nations et
l'indépendance la souveraineté des pays
des différents pays petit ou grand donc
voilà en général on voit les défi mais
mais on va aussi les les opportunités
maintenant ça dépend à nous comme les
pays comme les l'être humain ou comme
les
fonctionnaires de vraiment travailler de
de trouver les les points communs les
points positifs et constructifs pour
améliorer notre environnement de la vie
c'est ce que je peux vous dire
maintenant quelle était ma question oui
sur la géopolitique vous avez parlé le
risque le risque est important comment
comme vous me
dites on veut la stabilité on veut
partager le bonheur on veut on veut être
tranquille on veut être tranquille chez
nous j'ai compris certains vous accusent
de financer la déstabilisation de
financer des petits problèmes en mer
Rouge de financer des petits problèm
vers Israël de financer des mosquées en
Suède qui seraient des centres de
recrutement ou des centres d'espionnage
iranien pour menacer des dissidents
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur répondre
à ces G là c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
c'est d'un complot c'est pas un
complot vous
voyez voir les choses aussi simples que
ça certains nous accusent certains peut
accuser accuser n'importe quelle
personne n'importe quel pays de faire
ceci ici de faire
ceci cela est dans l'autre partie pour
nous les
Iraniens il faut parler précisément
de quel point on parle comme ça on peut
maintenant s'exprimer
et échanger et trouver vraiment les
contradictions ou la vérité parce que la
vérité doit être
révélée vous parlez de
financement bon tous les pays financent
partout dans le monde
donc si vous voyez même les PIR
ennemis d'un grand puissance à notre
voisin comme il
déclare maintenant il reçoit de l'argent
pour des objectifs je dis
paisibles avoir des amitié dans le monde
n'est pas
interdit avoir des solidarité avec les
opprimés nous sommes pas opprimés nous
sommes pas
interdits nous nous avons des
amitiés avec dans la région hors de
région en Afrique en Asie il vous reste
qui dans la région ami comment il vous
reste qui dans la région en tant qu'ami
Bachar etassad est tombé oui il vous
reste qui maintenant oui je vous parle
Bachar Assad était un ami et peu reste
toujours un ami il était au pouvoir il
n'est pas au pouvoir
mais c'est le seul dans le monde qui est
tombé par défaut ou
par
droit avec Bachar Assad l'histoire doit
être vraiment
euh révélé si vous voulez nous nons pas
nous n nons pas les relations que nous
avons entretenu avec Monsieur Bachar
Assad mais on n'avait pas une relation
basé sur une personne ou avec une
personne on
était
pendant
d'abord de la Révolution nous avons heé
à des problèmes nous avions eu vite temp
de
guerre
où beaucoup étaient derrière sa a celui
qui a été devenu un diable tout tout
mais c'est les question de
passé à ce moment-là les
Iraniens ils ont fait la guerre avec le
sang parce
que à l'époque nul pays
voulait
nous n équiper par les
armements et
donc nous avons par le sens S garder
notre pays l'intégrité territoriale et
notre souveraineté qu'est-ce qui vous
menaçait mais à l'époque c'était ça il
était V8 ans de guerre à
l'époque le père Bachar Assad ha Assad
était parmi ceux très rares qui ont
soutenu plus particulièrement moralement
l'Iran donc c'est une amitié qui qui
vient de cette époque et puis après
c'était son fils qui est venu mais notre
amitié était toujours
vivant
d'une dans une période à cause d'une
menace régionale importante qui était
Isis les combattants musulmans mais pas
musulmans il ils sont pas musulman parce
que le musulman ne coupe pas la tête
musulman ne coupe pas
donc à ce moment-là c'était une un
danger parce que ça ça a été
fait dans le
cadre d'une campagne de déstabilisation
de l'ensemble de Moyen-Orient ou l'Asie
de l'Ouest
oui par les Américains par les alliés
dans le région par
les les groupes soi-disant islamique
intégristes qui sont venus de de part et
d'autrre de de la Chine jusqu'à la
Russie
jusqu'à et puis c'était un danger pour
nous la vie des Iraniens c'est pourquoi
l'Iran par la demande de la Syrie est
entré pour éradiquer ce fléo dans la
région comme nous avons fait en ce qui
concerne l'Irak parce que les Isis
étaient dans la porte Bardot la capitale
si l'Iran n'intervenait
pas personne ne pouvait concevoir
aujourd'hui qu'elle devait être la le
plan de la géographie de la
région donc on est en train mesurer pour
contrer ce
fléon et puis après il y a eu et on
n'estit pas entré dans l'affaire les
affaires intérieures d'un pays ce qui
est notre ligne
rouge on était pas pour alimenter une
guerre un feu entre un peuple ou et un
les dirigeants de de ce
pays mais on est entré dans une
phase B de son pays la Syrie en fait est
tombé dans le piège des sanctions où ils
avaient besoin de se tenir et de
d'alimenter le peuple de de produire
l'électricité
de de sources de de l'énergie tout ça
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont pour ça que
Bachar s'est tourné vers la production
de captagon non je ne sais pas s'il a
fait ou si c'est vous êtes sûr qu'il a
fait bon il a fait mais je n'ai aucune
information et nous n'avons
aucune j'ai je n'ai pas entendu captagon
parce qu'en IR qu nous avons des des
stupéfiants divers qui viennent de part
et d'autre si vous voulez on peut en
parler après mais captagon je ne sais
pas c'est une invention je crois si
c'était le cas en tout cas les Iraniens
je peux vous couper ni était expert ni
était impliqué donc sil s'il faisait une
bêtise pour son peuple pour la région
c'est lui qui doit être en tout
cas pris comme responsable hein je peux
couper je vousen prie hein merci he vous
avez vu Bachar est tombé pourquoi vous
l'avez vous l'avez laissé tomber
deuxième chose est-ce que vous avez vu
les images qui sont sorties de Syrie
concernant les prisons les salles de
torture les prisonniers dans de
mauvaises conditions physiques et
morales vous avez vu ça
oui on a vu on a vu dans dans d'accord
sur le premier le fait qu'on ne sommt
pas nous sommes pas restés là ça veut
dire qu'on éétait pas
là pour défendre une personne ou les
dirigeants h euh tout en négligeant
l'osset du peuple le souhait du peuple
donc ça ça montre que l'Iran était
n'était pas là pour faire des
marchandises ou pour protéger donc ça
c'est euh c'est une vraiment une une
preuve négligeable
deuxièmement on était là et on
travaillait par les différentes mesures
politiques surtout de faire en sorte que
la réconciliation puisse établir parce
que une série faible c'est une région
déstabilisé c'est
notre compréhension vous voyez
maintenant ce qui se passe de gauche et
à droite ils ont attaqué ils ont
occupé donc dans le mécan que nous avons
eu avec la Russie la
Turquie le processus
d'année on
a essayé de faire en sorte que d'abord
la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale de la Syrie soit établie et
assurée et respecté par tout le monde et
puis pour aider à ce que le dialogue
entre le gouver ement de Monsieur Bachar
Assad et le parti d'opposition une
partie de du peuple opposé à son à sa
règne soit en tout
cas les relations soi plus assouplies et
puis la réconciliation c'est dans le
cadre dans ce cadre là qu'on a assisté à
la au progrès des discussion à Genève le
processus de
Genève mais bon ça roi du pays c'est un
président de la République c'est
certainsappellent dictateur il peuent il
peuvent toujours un quelqu'un qui peut
être appelé dictateur par quelques-uns à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur du pays la
même personne peut être appelée comme un
homme d'État souverain je ne sais pas
dans avec à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
du pays mais ce sont des mots qui qui
n'ont pas des des
des
éléments très structurés précises pour
nommer bon il était il était comme son
pèreemple non non non non je vous dis
parce que c'est vrai ils étaient d'une
famille d'un d'une partie d'une couche
religieuse minoritaire du pays mais ce
n'était pas le seul cas dans notre
région il y en a et il y a eu mais ce
qui importe c'est que la cohésion
sociale et la solidarité nationale soit
consolidée dans le but de progrès de
développement et de bien-être de tous
les citoyens sans sans discri
indiscriminatoirement si vous voulez ou
sans discrimination donc s'il y a une
faillite donc c'est le problème de la
personne on peut on peut toujours euh
euh en tout cas euh critiqué ou blâé ou
tout ça mais c'était le le président de
son peuple et son peuple était le le
seul et est toujours le seul à décidé
d'eux-même et de leur dirigeants c'est
c'est notre compréhension et puis voilà
vous vous parlez de de prison bon de
torture torture c'est c'est normal mais
mais à l'époque du chat nous avions de
tes prisons nous avions des tortures
répété et répété mais personne ne
parlait pas à l'époque dans le régime du
chat comment il avait pas Internet avit
pas internet il y avait pas les
téléphones portablebl oui mais mais ça
aide un peu mais mais à l'époque mais
aujourd'hui même il y a beaucoup
d'exemples de de poids de mesure donc à
l'époque c'était le cas à l'intérieur du
pays les les jeunes les académiciens les
combattants pour la liberté étai
opprimés mais le tapis rouge était
étendu partout dans le monde pour le
chat et sa famille corrompu
donc aujourd'hui on parle de ça oui
c'est le pouvoir a des vous voyez si si
on contrôle pas ça va
aller dans droite et gauche qu'est-ce
que vous ait qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
quand on on catégorise l'Iran comme
l'axe du mal c'est parce que c'est parce
que du côté iranien les Iraniens disent
ohah en face c'est le grand Satan et bon
les Occidentaux ils répliquent bah les
Iraniens c'est l'axe du mal est-ce que
vous êtes l'axe du
mal regardez qui est-ce qui nomblira
l'axe du
mal donc il faut le comprendre il faut
le
savoir qu'est-ce qu' a fait
l'Iran pour devenir l'axe du mal il n'a
pas aidé à ce que en
Afghanistan la les objectifs euh
politiqu euh pacifique dans l'intérêt du
peuple afcan soit avancé en Irak
l'Iran a fait à ce que le le
gouvernement l'état iraakien nos frères
aujourd'hui soit un État fort un peuple
inhumilié si vous voulez donc qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait pour être et et et
qu'est-ce qui a la qualité de nommer les
pays euh AE mal ou AE bien qui est-ce
qui axe mal et qui est-ce qui axe bien
donc pour nous
euh nous considérons que l'opinion
publique
internationale en général
ont la la maturité et la capacité de
distinguer ce qui est axe de mal ce qui
est axe de bien ou ce qui est un état
normal qui revendique sa souveraineté
qui revendique ses droits sur la scène
internationale qui revendique sa sa
dignité donc c'est ça qui compte à notre
point de vue tout en respectant tous les
réglementations Inter nationale mais on
a vu que ce qui
prétend d'avoir la capabilité de nommer
ou de blâmer les autres ont failli
d'exécuter même
leur
engagement tout à fait clair tout à fait
évident c'est vous voulez c'était quoi
les engagements comment quels
engagements par exemple
re
de la paix et de la
sécurité du global de la du monde vous
parlez de la paxe
Américana je parle des des pays
euh des pays des grands pays
garantissant la paix et la sécurité
internationale défin dans le
char des Nations Unies et à la tête
duquel le le grand grand puissance que
les États-Unis donc quand vous regardez
l'opinion publique regarde combien de
guerre combien de de bases militaires
hors de du territoire national partout
dans le monde font des
activitésah souvent contre les les la
stabilité la paix c'est c'est il faut il
faut le distinguer je crois que
aujourd'hui même nous avons des exemples
qui on montré que l'opinion publique
internationale y compris et surtout en
Occident s'agissant ce qui s'était passé
entre Israël et les Palestiniens et dans
les régions ce sont des exemples
vraiment évidentes mais bon encore une
fois nous en ce qui nous concerne nous
euh nous n'avons pas la possibilité et
nous ne prétendons pas de pouvoir
vraiment mettre fin à tous ces
inégalités et l'injustice sur la scène
internationale mais nous avec les autres
nous pouvons agir et nous avons décidé
d'agir comme nous avons fait une grande
révolution basée sur la morale et sur
l'éthique et la
légalité est-ce que vous étiez au
courant que le 7 octobre allait se
passer est-ce que vous aviez vous
service de renseignement au courant
queil y avait du mouvement et que ça
allait taper chez Israël non on ne
savait pas on a dit on a rudit donc nous
nous n'étions pas informés ni consultés
sur et nous n'avions même entendu qu'il
y aurait une telle un tel
événement une
telle révolte si vous voulez euh face à
de T situation de de vraiment désastreux
mais c'est une révolte ou c'est ou c'est
des attentats tout pour vous non vous
voyez la question palestinienne c'est
une une question qui dure il y a
quelques
décennies on a choisi de faire la paix
on a choisi de donner le droit aux
Palestiniens d'avoir une un pays une
patrie mais ça n'a pas été fait donc
c'est pour ça que vous les avez armés on
n pas on non nous navons pas armé les
les Hamas si on peut
Hebb n'est pas notre notre employé de
dire que voilà est-ce que vous avez
donné ou est-ce que vous n'avez pas
donné mais ce jour-là on peut procurer
l'arme partout dans le monde mais
accuser les uns et les autres mais mais
même si ils avaient donné quelques fusit
tout ça quelques missiles quelqueses
quelques roquettes les oui mais mais les
bombes qui ont été par les
Américains pour pénétrer je ne sais pas
combien de dizaines de mètres et de
ravager en tout euh tout entière de de
de petits rasés c'est ce ce quel
criticable mais l'Iran ce qui concerne
l'Iran nous n'avons pas donné l'arme
nous avons le soutien moral pour tous
les résistants devant l'occupation ce
n'est pas quelque chose que le
gouvernement iranien cache ou l'État
iranien cache celui qui est l'objet
d'une d'une oppression d'une d'une
vraiment annihilation d'une d'une
génocide à le soutien moral de de l'Iran
mais pour pour ce cas nous nous sommes
pas avocat de Hezbollah nous sommt pas
le maître de Hezbollah ils sont libres
et son bah en tout cas je je crois que
sur ce point-là nous on a on a rien à à
cacher
et c'est c'est une position basée sur
notre vraiment
euh principe
fondamental revenons un peu à
l'Iran paraît-il que vous avez des
prisons elles sont costaud en
Iran si nous avons des prisons non Costa
ce sont des prisons
rester matériellement je vous dis ou
physiquement je vous dis de l'air du
chat
donc c'est là
où nos peuples ont été torturés été
torturé mais nous avons changé les
prisons l'Inter de prison des
prisons parce que dès le début on voulez
que le préson soit une place pour si
vous voulez remédier tous les
défaillances des des détenus et de leur
faire une opportunité pour avoir une vie
hors de tout ces
ces ces dérivages ou ces ces fautes
c'est pourquoi
nous hors des des efforts déployés par
les
par l'ONG pour aider à ce que les
détenus seront sortis de leur isolement
et de
leur défaillance mentale ou morale le
gouvernement a fait en sorte que la
prison soit une place pour éducation ou
pour réhabilitation pourquoi vous dites
défaillance mentale dans une prison non
non non non je dis quand il n'y a pas
une défaillance
mental l'homme ne commet pas des crimes
l'homme ne commet pas des des fautes euh
graves qui méritent être détenu c'est
pour ça que je vous parle si on fait une
une faute importante une une action
contre la loi ça veut dire qu'il y a une
défaillance dans la tête il faut essayer
de la remise en en en ordre pour que
quand une fois il est sorti
ilol sera capable d'avoir
un un métier de de travailler et de de
se sentir en en paix en assurance dans
la société et puis de tourner un page
une page de sa de sa vie c'est là
l'objectif des prisons en Iran je vous
dis bon courage parce que chez nous ça
marche pas non plus hein non c'est je je
ne m'interre pas il y a des Français
dans vos prisons comment il y a des
Français dans vos prisons bien sûr nous
avons combien de français pour le moment
trois ressortissants français
malheureusement pourquoi ils sont en
prison chez vous ils sont vous voyez euh
monsieur es
euh vraiment être en prison c'est une
vraiment c'est une mauvaise chose
surtout en Iran ça pas l'air
d'êtrefortable pour pourquo surtout en
Iran dans les prisons moi je préféris
prison dans les pays nordiques oui c'est
c'est votre connaissance vous avez
raison de choisir être dans les pris
dans les les pays nordiques non pourquoi
non je ne sais d'être en
prison non je vous dis être en prison
c'est déjà comprenez pourquoi je vous
dis ça ici on entend dire qu'il y a des
torture en prison en Iran que c'est
compliqué qu'il y a beaucoup de violence
qu'on peut pas a téléphoner à sa famille
qu'on n' pas les bons médicaments que on
est à 25 dans une toute petite pièce
qu'on a peur
oui on dit beaucoup beaucoup de choses
mais je vous dis laissez-moi de vous
dire être en prison c'est une mauvaise
période de la vie d'un individu
n'importe qui
un 2uxè être en prison dans un pays
étranger c'est pire encore
pire qu'il soit coupable ou qu'elle soit
coupable ou ne pas coupable c'est
déplorable personne ne en tout cas en ce
qui nous concerne ne souhaite d'avoir
les prisonniers à l'intérieur de notre
pays ou bien à l'extérieur ou les
étrangers que soit à l'intérieur du pays
ou à leur pays d'origine pourquoi les
Français sont en prison chez vous là oui
oui je vous dis
donc en ce qui concerne il ils étaient
se les Français les ressortissant
français en prison chez
nous
bon tout le monde peut comprendre que
chaque pays a ses réglementations et ses
lois
c'est ses avantages et ses
vulnérabilités donc ça arrive des
occasions où un individu
commet une faute qui est contre les
réglementation interne d'un
pays bon il y a la
police les les gens de sécurité il y a
une
justice et il y a une des
lois noir sur blanc
dans une période assez tendue dans mon
pays
issu
d'une
d'une d'une imposition de sanction très
fort quel type oui imp positionition des
santion après la sortie
de des Américains de l'accord qu'on
avait signé à 1900 à
2015 donc des situations
difficiles
où surtout les jeunes parce que nous pas
les diplomates je ne parle pas de
diplomate mais je parle nous notre
génération nous avons passé beaucoup de
mauvais moments que ça soit la guerre
l'embargo les
sanctions
tous mais pour les jeunes
qui avec un effort
vraiment très fort par notre
état peut maintenant avoir une position
de de se sentir égal avec les
jeunes en Europe à l'Occident ou dans
les pays avancés ils veulent ils
revendiquent les choses les possibilit
viend on viendra au jeun après les trois
Français ils font quoi ils faisaient
quoi et pourquoi ils sont en prison oui
je vous ai dit il y a des
réglementations il y a la loi
c'est là il y a une prof c'est la
généralité que je vous ai dit
et je vais vous dire que laissez-nous de
N pas entrer dans le détail de ces trois
c'est important quand même non ok je
vous je vous donne
une réponse mais mais
mais révéler
parler de ce qui est parce que je
peut-être je ne sais pas même les
détails nous nous sommes dans une phase
de de si vous voulez de point
de de de change de point de vue ou
de
dialogue dialogue avec les autorités
franç le vous a contacté pour essayer de
faire sortir les Français ou bien sûr
c'est
c'est c'est un c'est une tâche primaire
pour tous les ministères des Affaires
étrangères pour tous les ambassades de
poursuivre leurs affaires je vous
explique
et nous nous sommes en train de discuter
avec eux et nous sommes dans une phase
où il ne faut pas
encore
ajouter des inquiétudes peut-être
euh à la morale des familles
1 et bon et de
d'entravers tout ce qu'on est en train
de se faire euh pour que nous
puissions utiliser les moyens nous comme
je vous dis le gouvernement iranien les
moyens dans le cadre de la
réglementation et la loi
auprès de de la justice iranienne de
pouvoir faire une avancée parce que pour
nous
euh nous ne souhaitons
pas
avoir nul dans notre prison vous voyez
donc encore une
fois vous avez parlé de la France je
vous ai répondu et j'ai je me suis
exprimé
dans les circonstances
diverses sur notre vision en Iran vers
la France et vers les Français et vers
la civilisation et la culture
française donc laissz un peu de
temps pour essayer
vraiment faire
sortir cette issue de ces de ce de ce
blocus
et n'alimentons pas les
les les accusations et les
insultes qui qui n ne cesse pas de euh
de de se prononcer et de se dire euh
dans ce tissu donc la publicité est là
les médias font leur choix mais
nous comme les gouvernement il faut que
nous nous concentrions sur l'essence de
cejet et trouver vraiment le meilleur
moyen de satisfaire tout le monde et de
faire en sorte que aussiôt que possible
ces trois soi libéré donc c'est notre
souhait c'est notre volonté et ce n'est
pas quelque chose de qu'
oui bon si on parlait un peu nucléaire
bien sûr vous avez la
bombe on n pas la bombe on n pas besoin
V de la bombe et la bombe n'a rien dans
notre
stratégie défensive
l'Iran n'a aucune stratégie offensive
mais par
contre par l'expérience par l'histoire
l'Iran
était jusqu'à même 2e guerre mondiale
l'objet
des attaques
extérieurs de la de l'occupation du
territoire de l'occupation même du pays
jusqu'à 2uxè guerre mondiale sans être
et sans vouloir être pris et chez un des
deux grands camps de de de de guerre
c'est c'est quoi les deux grandamp c'est
les États-Unis le bloc communiste non
non non non non à l'époque c'était 2ème
guerre mondiale oui la les les
coalitions et puis l'adversaire l'Iran
était neutre mais malgré ça l'Iran était
a été occupé et vous savez que nous
avons perdu pendant 300 dernières années
beaucoup de
territoires c'est aujourd'hui ce sont
des actualités c'est nous aussi on a
perdu beaucoup de territoirees nous
aussi on a perdu beauoup TER c'est vous
vous comprenez bien donc est-ce que vous
voulez pers ça vous manque ces
territoires que vous avez perdu non
pourquoi c'est on va on va on va essayer
d'avoir l'essentiel c'est que notre
peuple notre grand peuple soit heureux
si siil est heureux dans notre
territoire assez grande
1650000 1 650000 Carr dans un droit
géographique assez important assez
attractif avec 15 voisins donc avec les
ressources
naturel qui que Dieu nous a offert et
maintenant avec les jeunes et avec le
peuple qui sont très généreux très
savant très donc non il faut il faut que
nous faisions tout pour leur bonheur
revenons au nucléaire oui nucléaire
civil enrichissement d'uranium
stocksnet attaque de
2008 on commence par 2008 stocksnet oui
c'était quoi stocknet ouais c'était vous
savez très bien nous notre installation
nucléaire ça veut dire notre euh V
centrifugus complex comment vos
centrifugeuses oui bien sûr
c'était sous l'inspection de l'agence
toujours et la plus la plus le plus
nombreuse la plus nombreuse inspection
des centres nucléaires ou des des des
installations nucléaires ont été fait en
Iran donc dès le début on a eu un
objectif on travaille toujours dans la
même direction que nous nous avons
besoin la nucléaire comme une science
comme une technologie que nous devons
maîtriser et que nos jeunes méritent de
le de la maîtriser donc euh était
toujours sous l'inspection on n'a pas
trouvé aucun aucune déviation et
beaucoup de
après beaucoup de d'inspection mais
cette science c'est une science de
demain c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
très importante mais pour demain c'est
une après tous ces tous ces manques
d'énergie tout ça qu'on aura la
nucléaire sera la source vraiment je sur
l'énergie et puis sur le la les
médicaments sur la le soin vous savez
nous avons par exemple pour vous dire
800000 euh euh gens qui ont atteint le
cancer maintenant
même et nous le nucléaire nous avons eu
cette
technologie aux années 50 par les
Américains
OK et nous avons eu des coopération sur
le domaine nucléaire même avec la France
avec l'Allemagne
qui aurait
dû construire et finir le seul centrale
nucléaire iranien qui ont failli de le
faire à cause de la révolution à cause
de changement
de de régime si vou de l'État en Iran
donc pour nous nous nous ne cherchons
pas nous ne pouvons pas utiliser l'arme
de destruction massive ce n'est pas ni
idéologiquement ni dans la pensée des
Iraniens comme un peuple
de de 1000 ans de de quelques m000
années nous nous ne pouvons pas même
pendant la guerre Iran Irak nous n'avons
pas procédé à de à des tueries des
innocents mais ce qui a été fait par
notre adversaire qui a bombardé par la
bombe
chimique la ville
iranienne qui a bombardé même Terran
avec les missiles avec les
envionons fabriqués ici et là et donné
vous vous connaissez bien l'histoire
donc nucléaire pour nous c'est toujours
une nucléaire
euh dans la direction de la paix et la
sécurité et pour surtout
pour
euh pour le médicament don nous avons
besoin mais nous nous devons maîtriser
cette comme nous nous sommes en train de
d'essayer de maîtriser tout ce qui
revient de l'espace et des satellites
donc euh ce sont des accusations ici et
là mais on a créé une institution
internationale on le lui a donné des
atouts
nécessaires si on laisse les
observations politiques à côté cette
agence d' énergie atomique peut garantir
que les installations iraniennes ne
sonmt pas destinés et ne vont pas vers
une déviation quelconque on en est où
avec les les les inspections en ce
moment ils sont ils font ils font leur
travail ils sont en Iran ils font ils
font leur travail malgré que vous voyez
c'est JCP ou l'accord qu' nous avait
nous avons arrivé avec les les Européens
les Occidentaux et et aussi la Russie et
la Chine était fait pour garantir que
l'Iran n'a pas l'intention pour donner
une garantie pour assurer vraiment pas
donner une garantie assurer les autres
que non la nature de du nucléaire
iranien est pacifique
et pourquoi nous avons
accepté des actions
volontaires pour leur donner l'assurance
et l'accord et en
comprepartie les embargos et les
sanction
inhumain qui pesait beaucoup sur les
Iraniens la vie des Iraniens la santé
des iranien soit
levé bon ça a été fait en en ce qui
concerne les obligations les devoirs
iraniens mais en ce qui concerne les les
engagements de la partie adverse les
Européens les
Américains pendant la validité de cet
accord
euh bon il y a eu les défaillances il y
a eu toujours les la rétisence et puis
la si vous
voulez mais après il y a eu un
catastrophe encore parce que on avait
déjà fait tous nos engagements
satisfaire tous nos engagements mais
partie adverse a fini par
sortir good bye parce qu'il pensait que
vous faisiez de l'enrissement parce
queils vous ont vu avec des missiles
balistiques parce qu'ils vous ont vu
avec des drones un peu partout oui ben
mais mais un pays comme je vous ai dit
on a ouvert la les yeux après la
Révolution
à
1900 euh
98 avec les agissements dans la
région avec la manipulation en cour
Kurdistan iranien il y a eu des attaques
aux garnaisons il y a eu des pillages
des garnaisons il y a eu une une
revendication de
l'indépendance donc il y a des
agissements dans le Baluchistan iranien
même àousestan iranien parce que c'est
l'Iran c'est une mosaïque de de
différentes ethnies des peuples donc et
mais tout court après on a eu la guerre
une guerre dont une armée une une une
armée équipée par les les armements euh
sophistique de l'Est de l'Ouest ont
attaqué on occupé une grande partie de
l'Iran donc 8 ans on a battu avec le
sang pour sauvegarder c'est pourquoi
après presque 200 ans à la fin d'une
guerre on n'a pas perdu 1 centimètre de
notre territoire et cela grâce à la la
bravure et la le sacrifice tout à peuple
y compris les jeunes les vrais jeunes
donc pourquoi il y a des faux jeunes
nous comment il y a des faux jeunes non
non non non je vous dis que les gens qui
étaient vraiment qui s'étaient consacrés
à au pays à la patrie au peuple ils sont
ils sont pas les jeunes comme si vous
voulez les jeens de roue les gens qui
vont à l'université les gens non ils se
sont sacrifiés pour qu'un peuple pu
puisse lever sa tête donc et après il n
a pas eu de de bon jour pour nous il y a
eu toujours des sanctions des
accusations des
de en tout cas des des cous de gauche à
droite l'Iran doit être capable de
sauvegarder son intégrité territoriale
sa souveraineté nationale c'est une r
revendication des Iraniens ce n'est pas
le souhait de de tel gouvernement ou de
tel gouvernement ou même de de souet du
Guide suprême parce que le guide suprême
aussi exprime ce qui est le souhait du
peuple iranien avec toute
diversité tout
compris on continue un petit peu
géopolitique est-ce que vous avez vu la
la vidéo de Wesley Clark le général
Wesley Clarc qui date de
matthuselem concernant le fait qu'il a
été se baladé au P il y a un de ses
anciens collègues qui lui dit oh là là
juste après le 11 septembre tu sais pas
ce qu'on va faire on va passer par tel
tel tel pays on va tous les faire tomber
et ça finit par l'Iran ou vous avez vu
cette vidéo là moi j'ai entendu vraiment
je me souviens pas complètement vu mais
j'ai entendu ça et ils m'ont raconté
ça vous
voyez on est conscient des
défauts des défis et
c'est pourquoi on a essayé de nous
équiper de tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour une défense nationale comment on
fait pour arranger les choses maintenant
parce que j'ai compris votre point de
vue j'ai compris que les sanctions ça va
ça vous avez un petit peu tendu
recroquvier et puis en mode
défensifis s'ils ont été tendus ou non
je ne peux pas dire d'accord mais je
peux vous dire que les Iraniens peuvent
trouver leur voie d'accord donc c'est
pour c'est dans le cadre là que comment
on fait pour arranger les choses entre
vous les Iraniens vous les États-Unis
vous la France vous peut-être la Chine
bientôt comment on fait pour arranger
les
choses rapidement non non un autre point
de vue ce sont les choses sont déjà
arrangé parce que l'Iran a une bon à
chacun sa son jugement les Israéliens
ils sont un peu fâchés avec vous en ce
moment non même s'ils sont fâchés avec
nous fâchés avec eu aussi nous sommes
pas fâchés c'est
pourquoi après 15 ans
de des actions euh bouleversantes les
actions militaires les actions
malicieuses
St net vous avez fait allusion mais il y
a eu des scientifiques iraniens qui ont
été coupé il y a eu des attaques sur les
NA sur nos installation nucléaire c'est
c'est Atta par cyberataque non pas cyber
non pas cyber cyber
éta mais l'attaque par les Dron par les
ça cré des vocations de à cœur chez vous
le fait que vous fassiez attaquer avec
une clé USB qui traînait qui allait se
mettre à jour sur les serveur de foot en
Asie ça ça a créé des vocations chez les
jeunes bah bien sûr chaque iranien sent
vraiment brisé quand il y a une une
agression à son identité à son pays donc
ça c'est normal donc il y a eu plus de
15 ans et ils ont ils sont venus tuer
notre hôte en Iran à l'intérieur à Tran
ils sont tirés sur notre consulat
général et une
une un bâtiment diplomatique toérant en
Syrie ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient qui les Israéliens vous avez
parlé des Israéliens mais nous qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait aux Israéliens bah vous
avez un peu armé les gens qui les
embêtent un peu sur le sur la région euh
vous avez mis un petit peu des armes un
peu partout c'était une réponse un par
un donc l'Iran n'a pas n'a pas intervenu
n'a pas fait une action à l'intérieur de
l'Israël vous l'acceptez bien donc il y
a
pas maintenant on a donné les arm au
Hezbollah
hein est-ce que Hezbollah attaqu Israël
et
quand vous avez la réponse à votre
question oui oui je vous
dir j'ai pas leses j'ai pas non
donc prétendez quand on prétend on doit
aller à telle
dateb attir un missile vers telle ville
après 7 octobre c'est autre chose mais
avant
là pour défendre le Liban parce
que même avant la Révolution
iranien chaque fois qu'Israël voulait Il
ent dans les pays voisin et surtout au
Liban 1978 c'était le cas ça c'était
avant la
Révolution
1982 est né de
zéro
mais mais à cause de
l'agression continuelle
d'Israël ils se sont
sentis de devoir être plus fort avec un
soutien de l'ensemble du peuple
libanais donc vous savez bien que
lebouah était très aimé et par les chiit
et par les chrétiens
et on peut on peut toujours on peut
toujours dire mais mais ils ont ils ont
une force
politique une force défensive ils
étaient
toujours donc
vous on peut toujours dire droite et
gauche mais pour nous Hezbollah éit un
un ami mais un ami indépendant assez
mature pour gérer ses affaires et il
était très très en tout cas
mesuré une une une une force politique
au
Liban on parle de politique intérieur en
Iran vous pouvez on peut essayer oui ABS
oui qu'est-ce que les Occidentaux vous
reprochent on a vu le mouvement femme
femme vie
liberté nous en tant qu'internaut on a
accès à tout plein de vidéos tourné dans
vos rues on voit des femmes se faire
tapé par des femmes qui sont tout voilé
la police démeur on voit des femmes
envoyées en prison on voit des femmes
envoyées en prison parce que folle selon
V critères on voit des rappeuses des
chanteuses se faire
ennuyer pourquoi comment comment vous
percevez la chose et comment vous
percevez que la popul la population
occidentale puisse être ému de voir des
artistes et des jeunes femmes se faire
ennuyer comme ça voir torturé voire
tabassé voir morte
oui vous
voyez monsieur Sky l'Iran est une
société
multiculturelle
et il y a différentes ethnies
différent culture et traditions c'est la
première
chose donc euh il y a des comportements
et les coutumes différentes dans les
différentes parties
de la du
territoireen c'est une
chose deuxè il y a les réglementation et
la
loi ratifié par la volonté de la
majorité du peuple comm partout dans le
monde pour un citoyen
quiiconque il faut obéir
sinon on peut toujours aimé d'uneun un
style de
vie de l'extrême droite ou l'extrême
gauche ou le milieu ou un peu gauche et
un peu droite donc la loi doit être
appliquer comme s'applique partout dans
le monde Je peis vous poser une question
dans votre loi oui est-ce qu'il est
marqué qu'on peut tabasser les gens non
non mais vous savez très bien il y a
toujours une éventualité
d'exaction individuel hors la
loi par une
euh situation mentale moins équilibré ou
ça ça ce n'est pas
l'exception n'est pas généralité et je
vous
dis personne dans le monde peut
prétendre aimer le peuple
iranien que le peuple le gouvernement et
l'État
iranien parce que ce sont nos filles et
nos garçons ce sont de nous
tous ça arrive un
incident il faut
laisser le peuple les les mouvements
social les mouvements
politiques l'Assemblée nationale de
traiter le les choses et de résoudre le
problème venir et
intervenir dans un contexte
d'assimilation et dans d'une position
suprématiiste
accuser alimenter manipuler encourager
et fait en sorte que la l'extrémisme les
les exactions euh se répètent dans un
pays on n'est pas bon ça ça n'aide pas
et ça ne dure même même dure pas et
essayez de faire sans que les autres
nous ressemble non respectons la
diversité laissons les soins au peuple
et aux élus du peuple de de ménager et
de on n'est pas content s'il y a une
exaction quelconque dans n'importe
quelle prison dans la car pour
rue ou avenue en Iran non on on se
rectifie c'est la démocratie la
démocratie tout le monde sait je ne veux
pas vous faire un exemple d'ici et là
mais à chaque gouvernement sa manière de
maîtriser à ce que la paix et la
stabilité du pays nous soit pas abîé qui
donne l'occasion aux autres de venir
intervenir et nul veut
voudra bien assumer les responsabilités
surtout dans notre
région qui est une région
toujours de manipulation comment vous
percevez que votre diaspora
euh écrivent des livres contre le régime
écrivent que le peuple n'est pas libre
vont chanter le fait que le peuple
iranien n'est pas libre vont nous dire
que ce qui ce qui est décrit comme le
gouvernement des Molas est corrompu
occupe toutes les places verrouille le
système démocratique contrôle les
élections contrôle la police persécute à
l'intérieur les dissidents et va
chercher les dissidents à l'extérieur
des frontières comment vous voyez toutes
ces femmes prendre position contre votre
gouvernement c'est normal c'est légitime
il y a des preuves elle pourquoi elles
font ça tel que vous me décrivez votre
pays on va passer un mois de vacances
là-bas on verra rien mais quand je lis
le témoignage des Iraniens à l'extérieur
de votre
pays c'est pas la même chose ils ont des
vidéos des preuves des gens esquintés
par des années de jaolle de prison chez
vous des années de
torture comment vous percevez
ça-ce est-ce que vous pouvez leur
répondre non je ne veux pas les répondre
leur répondre d'abord
deuxièmement diaspora
ou la 3è 4e génération iranienne qui ne
sont pas maintenant
iranienes et qui disent des choses ils
sont libres de le dire parce qu'ils sont
ils vivent dans
une société où il y a les moyens de se
prononcer on décord c'est pour eux tant
mieux pour
eux mais pour
nous comme je vous ai
dit depuis la
Révolution moins de 3 ans de la ré de la
victoire une violence a été éclatée à
l'intérieur du
pays par les jeunes par les gens qui
voulai considérer le pays comme un
gâteau et pouvoir pouvoir avoir leur
part de
gâteau la fin ils ont tué 17000
personnes innocents 17000 personnes
innocents et ils ont fuit à l'extérieur
ils ont
pris
refuge dans les pays
étrangers et il y a a une
famille qui était
corrompue
corrompue qui était qui agissait comme
le vrai dictateur que vous devez qui qui
qui chat le chat d'Iran il est sorti
avec tous les ressources des Iraniens
avec des argents tout
tout et avec eux ce qui
réjouissaient dans un pays où
la l'âge de comment dirais-je
la de vie était 50 ans l'esérance de vie
espérance de vie 50 ans ou 55 ans
où il n'y a il y a eu moins de 40 %
d'alphabétisation il y a eu vraiment des
jeul il faut faut vraiment nommer les
prisons et les les bon lieux même de
Terran comme le jeul pour les Iraniens
donc ils sont sortis les gens qui ont
qui ont profité du
régime royal de de s'enrichir et puis de
sortir donc depuis ce moment-là l'Iran
et le peuple iranien était sous le
bombardement médiatique avec
les la
possibilité que qui ont été
octroyé par le pays qui pensaient que
cette
révolution verra sa fin très
bientôt donc
aujourd'hui je crois bon on n'est pas
nous ne sommes pas complets nous avouons
que nous avons un parcours très long à
aller pour avoir une société digne à ce
que nous souhaitions vraiment à ce que
notre religion souhaite à ce que notre
culture et notre notre civilisation
exige mais le cours de perfection ne
s'arrête jamais avec intimidation
manipulation la campagne médiatique tout
ça mais mais vous savez ici ce n'est pas
l'occasion n parler qui sont
derrière regardez les la décision la
récente décision de
l'administration américaine qui ont
coupé
l'aide aux groupes Iraniens qui
prétendaient sont en train de de de de
faire euh campagne contre l'Iran et le
peuple iranien pourquoi ils ont fait ça
parce que par vous avez pas besoin
d'argent vous le faites à leur place
comment quand on vous quand on voit les
vidéos oui j'ai vu des vidéos très
récentes d'ailleurs où par exemple il y
a des femmes toutes voilées qui courent
après les autres la police démeur oui
oui mais mais vous voyez je dis non oui
oui vraiment je ve je vous dis c'est un
agent qui est en train d'exécuter la loi
mais peut-être il c'est pas vraiment la
meilleure façon d'appliquer la loi mais
ce n'est pas une
enimité est-ce qu'il y a eu des
sanctions est-ce qu'il y a eu des
sanctions à l'encontre de ces gens-là
bah bien sûr bien s qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
eu comme comme comme sanction il y a les
lois il y a les lois il y a les la la
justice qui agisse vraiment très forte à
l'égard toute infraction ou exaction
dans le dans l'application
de une parenthèse très récemment vous
avez relâcher un prisonnier français qui
faisait du tourisme chez vous oui il
était avec son
camping-car votre pays est magnifique il
a pris son drone il voulait faire des
images de lui bon il a fait combien
d'années de prison chez vous pour
ça avec avec la qualification que vous
faites je ne sais pas de qui vous êtes
en train de parler mais je ne veux pas
même savoir avec la qualification non
non non avec la qualification que vous
faites il doit être sur je ne sais pas
vraiment je ne sais pas vous dire que il
doit être dans le paradis au lieu de
l'Iran mais pourquoi ou pourquoi parce
que vous dites il était contouriste il a
eu sa voiture tout ça donc pour rien il
a été arrêté parce qu'il a fait voler un
drone peut-être là où il fallait pas non
je ne sais pas c'est vous vous vous
rigolez mais mais c'est peut vous
rigolez parce que s'il y a une
infraction la loi est là pour être
appliqué sans vouloir savoir de qui vous
parlez mais sans
preuve on fait pas on fait
rien aux autres donc vous dites c'est un
touriste il y a chacun année autour de
10 millions de touristes qui visitent
notre pays et nous avons
Assouli le mécanisme de de délivrance de
visa pour des dizaines de pays on a
enlevé tout ça
et on a donné l'occasion pour les
touristes même d'obtenir le visa à
l'aéroport parmi ces 10 millions
il y a 10
15 qu'est-ce qu'ils font et qu'est-ce
que les autres font et ne font pas donc
B vous vous si vous voulez bien je veux
vous assurer que ce sont des chiffres ce
n'est pas l'ambassadeur d'Iran qui parle
vous pouvez vérifier même donc ce n'est
pas
euh sans rien
peut-être vous dites pour cette
infraction cette sanction punition
et trop
ou je dis bon c'est votre avis
essayons dans notre pays de faire en
sorte que vraiment les
infractions
aé à des sanctions plus appropriées ce
que nous faisons il y a une une
assemblée il y a une
assemblée
assemblée de Parlement en Iran qui ont
la tâche de Act d'actualiser les choses
mais il y a une tolérance aussi à
l'égard de tout le monde et comme je
vous ai dit un touriste pour les
Iraniens c'est c'est quelqu'un envoyé de
Dieu pour nous donc on n'a pas vous
voyez
les vous non je je dis on a la tendance
de voir un par million un par 10
millions mais on ne voit pas que les
touristes de votre pays qui ont qui sont
partis en Iran le couple avec leur
voiture ils ont
euh tourné dans tout le pays avec des
des vidéos sur l'Internet qui disent
voilà on était che cet iranien on était
là on a on a été accueilli ici on a été
accueilli là et on a bon il il faut voir
ça qu'est-ce qu'il faisait et les autres
ne faisaient
pas nous vraiment nous ne voulons pas
nous voulons les touristes mais nous ne
voulons pas ns touristes donc chaque
pays c'est la même je je crois que
partout dans le monde si vous quelle est
la majorité pour qu'une femme puisse se
marier en Iran c'est à partir de quel
âge question internet à quel âge le
mariage des petites filles en Iran il
n'y a pas il y a pas de
majorité non non depuis 16 ans on peut
être éligible pour son mari à 16 ans 16
ans mais à la par la vie de la cours
sinon 18 ans c'est l'âge de l'élection
c'est l'âge de mariage mais mais ces
jour-ci les jeunes ne se marri pas le
même flot que vous vous avez touché
pendant des années récentes ou des
années vous êtes plus vieux que ça les
jeunes préfèrent de se marier après 27
ans 29 ans 30 ans j'ai un fils 33 ans
qui n'est pas encore qui ne s'est pas
encore marié non ce n'est pas seulement
l'argent non c'est non c'est c'est
l'entendre c'est les gens d'aujourd'hui
veulent vraiment se connaître et
connaître les autres les autres et
choisissent mais pas peut-être dans les
parties lointains lointain du pays dans
les dans les dans les petit villages ou
ça il y a des mariage en à l'âge même
même un peu moins mais ce n'est pas
répandu ce n'est pas c'est légal comment
est-ce que c'est légal non vous voyez je
vous dis quelque chose sur la voie
islamique à partir de l'âge où la
fille peut sentir pouvoir être une un
maman peut se marier
ok donc l' mariage il y a le mariage
religieux il y a le mariage officiel le
mariage officiel on voit dans un dans un
office dans un bureau où est mandaté
accrédité pour enregistrer le mariage
tout ça on a le droit d'avoir plusieurs
femmes en Iran en Iran on n pas
non plusieurs femmes on ne peut pas nous
nous la majorité des Iraniens ont une
femme
ok mais plusieurs oui oui oui non ça
suffit non ça suffit même même plus que
ça mais vous savez bien
euh nous avions dans le passé un homme
de femmees mais vraiment très rare très
très rare mais aujourd'hui c'est les
gens ne se marient pas et vous voulez
qu'on on se marie avec trois ou quatre
c'est comment ça se passe
l'homosexualité en Iran comment comment
ça se passe l'homosexualité en Iran le
l'homosexualité l'homosexualité n'est
pas reconnue dans la loi iranienne on a
le droit d'être homosexuel en Iran n'est
pas autorisé n'est pas reconnu dans les
lois iraniens mais que ce soit pas
reconnu je veux bien comment que ce soit
pas reconnu je veux bien est-ce que
c'est autorisé non c'est n'est pas
autorisé non ça veut dire vous voyez on
nentre pas dans les dans la vie privée
des citoyens vous voyez c'est la
première chose parce que bon tout tout
peut se passer dans une maison dans un
ce n'est pas même même l'islam ne permet
pas d'une telle si vous voulez
intervention mais sur la loi non on
n'accepte pas non seulement en Iran on
n'accepte pas mais dans les autres pays
dans le dans
le dans dans les pays occidentaux si il
y en a des pays qui ne reconnaît pas
mais nous nous ne voulons pas accuser
les autres blâ les autres non chacun son
on peut aller en prison si on est
homosexuel en Iran comment on peut aller
en prison moi honnêtement je ne sais pas
est-ce que c'est même le phénomène
so soi-même est entré dans la loi je ne
sais pas mais ce que je sais ce que
l'homosexualité n'existe
pas ne se voit pas
et not le pas par notre culture religion
et coutume et tradition
donc bon soit on ne voit pas même un
Terran on ne voit
pas s'il y a des cas isolés comme je
vous ai dit hein question internet en
parlant des femmes en rappelant que la
première femme ayant obtenu la médaille
field Maria mirzani
Mirani merci et iranienne ne serait-il
pas temps de relâcher la pression sur
les
femmes si la pression était sur les
femmes Mariam mirzani ne pouvait pas
être à la hauteur de la science mondiale
ça veut dire que
Mar n'était pas une seul en Iran nous
avons
maintenant 60 % des
étudiants qui sont plus de 4 millions
maintenant sont des
filles plus de 70 % des étudiants dans
la science et dans l'ingénierie sont des
filles et il y a une présence des filles
dans tous les autres universités du
monde les Iraniens et à l'intérieur du
pays nous avons pour tous les goûts des
des universités partout et cela partout
dans le pays ce qui est rare et on a
investi beaucoup pour que les filles les
femmes prennent sa place dans la société
c'est par la révolution que les femmes
nos mères sont
entrain de chez nous comme le femme de
ménage de venir de s'exprimer pour la
liberté pour l'égalité pour la justice
pour la République si vous voulez donc
nous nous avons fait même pendant la
guerre comme je vous ai dit on a créé
des universités partout dans le pays et
on a donné une subvention très très
importante pour que les jeunes Iraniens
ne se passent pas leur vie dans la rue
ou pour rien donc comment ça se passe la
peine de mort chez vous nous avons la
peine de mort par quoi par pandaison
injection létale non non c'est par
pendaison je vous je vous explique il y
en a combien je vous dirai
ou vous voyez h euh la punition c'est
une chose c'est un
phénomène créé par les pays les
États pour
euh rectifier le comportement des gens
pour prévenir les euh les infraction les
les délits si vous voulez pourider pour
faire peur ça ça à son sens il y en a
parce que vous devez euh euh prévenir
euh et avoir une comment dirais-je
préventive comme des mesures préventives
à l'égard de ceux qui ne veulent pas se
soumettre à l'ordre et à la loi et la la
l'harmonie de la société c'est c'est une
chose importante et chaque société
décide est-ce que cette punition est
capable à le potentiel vraiment
de de faire le service de tel
service parce que chaque exaction dans
les
devoirs au
droit
Orte à au au devoir des au droit des
autres bon il y en a des pays qui
ont su supprimer la la peine de mort
mais il y a des pays qui ont la peine de
mort comme une mesure de punition même
de prévention comme vous avez dit de
faire peur mais pourquoi pas pour que
les gens ne commettent pas des crimes
graves
chez nous nous avons la peine de mort
parce que nous nous avons des délits des
crimes qui sont vraiment qui ont une
nature désastreuse si vous
voulez par exemple pour
le trafiquant de drogue on est dans un
pays proche de ce
triangle stupéfiant
et nous nous ne voulons pas que N
jeunes
purifie à cause des des drogues
importées par les dilair par les
trafiquant vous voyez les gens qui
cherchent de l'argent donc ils viennent
et vendent
leur et sur ce celui-là nous avons
beaucoup souffert parce que beaucoup de
jeunes
sont tombés dans le piège de stopian et
ils ont vraiment détruit leur vie et la
vie de leurs
proche en plus il y a une une route de C
africain de drogue d'apporter le drogue
vers la Turquie l'Europe tout
ça nous nous avons perdu vous savez 4000
polices iraniens ont perdu leur vie pour
contrer ce ce courant de trafic de
drogue donc on
est on a une tête haut on n'a pas au
début on a pu avoir quelques assistances
techniques aux pays qui ont les
possibilités l'expérience tout ça
lesquel mais nous les pays européens
même les pays européens nous avons pu
obtenir quelques chiens euh quelques
expériences quelques méthodes quelques
même même instruments pour superfiser
dans la dans la nuit le nocturne que
vous dites donc
euh et on est on est un pays très très
soucieux de ne pas permettre que notre
pays soit notre jeune soit euh vraiment
dans une situation euh de purification
de de de destruction à cause de
stupéfiant donc pour vous
dire selon les informations que vous
pouvez trouver amnestie internationale
Etel euh
% des peines de mort sont appliqué en
Iran pour les trafiquants de drogu de
grande quantité c'est combien grande
quantité comment à partir de combien la
quantité ce qui est ce qui est interdit
ça doit être quelques grammes de héroï
jusqu'à quelques Kilogramm de
d'opion mais normalement les gens sont
structurés organisé qui viennent de
l'Est du pays passer par euh le centre
du pays venir vers le nord ou de l'Est
euh de venir vers la mer et puis entrer
dans dans donc
euh nous nous ne pouvons pas euh tolérer
ce ce type de chose la peine de Mor
c'est ça donc la plupart et les autres
et pour les autres et pour les autres il
y a des cas où il y a une une crime
commis contre quelqu'un tuer
quelqu'un pour ça aussi on a vraiment on
a essayé beaucoup faire et dans le dans
le niveau du gouvernement et dans le
niveau des caricatives et du peuple
pour donner le moyen à des familles
victimes de de gracier l'homme il y a
deux prétendants le gouvernement et la
famille de victimes donc on essit on a
beaucoup essayé mais sont trop rares
même nous avons des cas où la personne
est restée 20 ans dans la prison en
attendant que la la la grâce de la
famille soit obtenue
parce qu'on on voyait que le détenu a
des enfants de la famille à des à un
comportement vraiment tout à fait
équilibré et calibré donc et puis nous
avons créé par l'essai que vous avez
donné des punitions euh qui succède qui
qui remplace genre des coups de fouet
des coups de bâton nous n'avons pas
lapidation coup de fouet vous ne pouvez
pas trouver en Iran j'ouvre une
parenthèse ou s'il vous plaît ça fait
1h31 qu'on est ensemble est-ce qu'on
peut continuer un peu plus je vous
avveis donné ma parole pour 1 he non non
non on peut on peut si vous souhaitez si
vous souhaitez si vous pensez que c'est
util j'ai pris ma soiré pris non non je
continuez votre réponse
donc non nous n'avons pas ce type de
chose parce que par le temps on a
vraiment essayé de remplacer les
punitions par par l'évolution de la
société aussi c'est tout à fait normal
parce que de comme je vous ai dit nous
avons maintenant une espérance de vie de
76 ans nous avons 99 % d'alphabétisation
dans le pays nous
avons le peuple qui qui vraiment mérite
tout le respect et qui veulent être être
digne qui méritent être digne même je
peux vous ouvrir une parenthèse Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur donc oui bien sûr pourquoi
pas en
Iran on voit des des filles des femmes
se dévoiler parce qu'elles en ont assez
de porter le voile et elles font tapé
dessus et puis on les voit elles en ont
tellement marre qu'elles se mettent
pardonnez-moi l'expression elles se
foutent à poil
pour attirer les caméras les regards
pour montrer leurs conditions que bah
elle veut pas por elles veulent plus
porter le voile elles sont modernes
elles sont éduquées elles veulent la
liberté comme vous avez dit elles sont
nombreuses la société civile iranienne
et jeune et ils en ont
assez qu'est-ce que vous ça vous fait
quel âge vous avez déjà moin 35 ans à
peu près pe prs
61 ça vous fait quoi vous comprenez C
oui je comprends bien vous voyez
monsieur Sky vous parler ils en ont
marre comment vous pouvez parler de ça
ah bah ça se voit non c'est ce sont des
cas isolés il y en a beaucoup il faut
combien il y en a bah suffisamment pour
non suffisamment ça veut dire quoi quel
est standard vous vous utilisez ça comme
je vous dis par exemple par exemple par
exemple dans un pays dans Le
Mire il y a dans une société où je vais
il y a les femmes voilé ou les femmes
telles à ce moment-là je prétends oui le
pays et tout occupé par les les foulards
ou
inverse il y a des
cas vous acceptez qu'il y a des mors il
y a des des des étiques qui était des
euh des valeurs dans un pays qui doit
être respecté et on respecte et vous
parlez d'une fille qui a fait ça
plusieurs combien et vous dites ils en
ont marre ils en ont marre de faire
quoi donc de se soumettre à la religion
à la religion bon ils peuvent la société
iranienne n'est pas 100 % religieuse il
y a la com
comment até je ne sais pasé mais nous
avons une communauté
chrétienne nous avons une communauté
juive qui vivent dans leur traditions
qui vivent dans leur manière de de de
comportement individuellement ou dans la
société et vous parlez il y a combien
d'âteur combien d'â
âé êtreâé ou n pas
c'est une c'est une un choix ou une
conviction individuelle et interne et
puis prétendre qu'il y a de cas euh vous
voyez
euh euh on faut toujours il y a deux
tendances pour voir le phénomène et puis
pour porter imposer son jugement
là-dessus sans avoir pris en cons
fdération
aucun
élément directement ou indirectement lié
à ce
comportement mais peut-être une tendance
aussi de pouvoir d'attribuer tous
ces toutes
ces comportements à l'extérieur nous
disons non en Iran nous devons nous
perfectionner mais nous devons aussi
faire attention que la les
manipulations ne viennent pas toucher
nos jeunes nos filles et nos fils donc
il y a un travail un grand travail à
faire comme je vous avais dit déjà et
nous nous sommes peut-être au début même
de cette de ce chemin qu'on
avait choisi et qu'on va continuer
sûrement
qu'est-ce qui leur arrive à ces jeunes
qui se dévoilent ou qui font des actes
euh en se mettant toute nu dans la rue
qu'est-ce qui leur arrive elles vont en
prison elles vont en hôpital
psychiatrique elles font taper dessus
elles font pas taper dessus ça dépend ça
dépend monsieur dans une famille vous
avez quatre enfants cinq enfants chaque
enfant fait un délire mais vous prenez
en
considération
le l'atmosphère les
en tout cas
les la situation où cette erreur ou
cette cette élit a été fait comme je
vous ai dit et elles sont nos filles
quoi qu'il en soit et personne ne peut
être plus affectueuse et plus
responsable que nous à l'égard de nos
filles donc c'est une conviction et il y
en a des autres filles qui font un
comportement plus ou moins dans le cadre
de loi mais tous sont respectés dans le
pays monsieur mais bon vous vous n'avez
pas visité les films de l'Iran même même
même à l'époque je ne veux pas entrer en
détail mais mais l'Iran c'est une c'est
une un pays libre si je vais en Iran je
peux boire une bière
B pas légalement sûrement parce que
c'est interdit bien sûr bien sûr dans
les magasins vous pouvez pas trouver
parce que c'est c'est interdit c'est
interdit en Iran il y a les boissons ce
si je bois une bière en Iran qu'est-ce
qui peut m'arriver comment si je bois
une bière en Iran qu'est-ce qui peut
m'arriver rien vous pensez qu'en Iran
maintenant personne ne boit alcool non
c'est il ben si comme je vous ai
dit le privé c'est le privé et donc par
la loi est interdit dans entrer dans
l'au privé des peuples mais celui qui
vient d'or et montre agressive à Gard
des autres par le pied de de de boisson
de tel hôtel bon il il sera responsable
de ce de son
comportement comment je fais pour
trouver de la bière en Iran pour pour
trouver de la bière je fais comment pour
trouver de la bière en Iran je n'ai pas
je n'ai jamais cherché d'aller prendre
la bière en Iran mais je crois que vous
allez trouver tout ce que vous voulez
mais sûrement dans le milieux que vous
connaissez les quel milieux que je
connais non non non
votre quoi attention ah non je pas
question internet non vraiment
c'est je vais en prendre une à la volée
est-ce que l'État iranien a mené
l'enquête sur la double explosion du
port de beyouth au Liban ont-ils mené
l'enquête sur l'assassinat de raficari
sur celui de lookman Slim
voyez pourquoi le gouvernement
iranien doit
faire une
enquête pour ce qui se passe maintenant
en Alaska est-ce que on est responsable
de faire lib c'est quoi c'est un super
pays avec des super gensalas aussi c'est
parfait même donc l'Iran n'a pas une
responsabilité à faire est dans les
affaires intérieures et mettre de doigt
sur celui-là sur celui-ci il n'a pas une
responsabilité quelconque et n pays n'a
pas responsabilité le pays qui a qui se
sent responsable de le faire bon il le
fasse est-ce que vous faites de
l'ingérence comment est-ce que vous
faites de l'ingérence est-ce que vous
sponsorisez des des gens à l'étranger
pour imposer be de points de vue non
est-ce que vous avez un groupe de cyber
haackur qui va je dirais de cyberpirate
d'ailleurs qui va aller neutraliser ou
aller chercher de l'information nous
nous n'avons pas aucune groupe
ou groupe quelconque pour aller
intervenir dans ce type de et on n pas
besoin pour de le faire quand vous avez
mené votre évolution qu'est-ce que vous
avez trouvé dans l'ambassade
américaine bon ça c'est même nous avons
publié tout ce qu'on a pu trouver nous
nous l'avons pas trouvé c'était les
jeunes et
étudiants à l'époque sans permission
sans autorisation mais avec un souçon
pour l'ingérence et l'intervention des
Américains dans les affaires intérieur
du pays qu'ils ont avoué vous savez h
euh
euh les propos de
de de Madame Clinton et l' de s'excuser
de Madame albriit si je me trompe pas
qui ont fait une intervention dans les
affaires iraniennes et une grande
partie de la déviation du pouvoir de
l'époque iranien vers la vraiment vers
euh vers une maîtrise individuelle d'un
grand pays comme l'Iran tout le monde
sait cette lequel
pays donc c'est dans le climat de la
révolution de la du rejet de
cette situation que quelques étudiants
ont décidé d'aller
et voir ce qui se passe vraiment à
l'intérieur de de l'ambassade des
États-Unis et ils sont tombés après
après voir euh une quantité de de
documents brûlés et
détruits des papier qui ont ont ont eu
dans la situation de pouvoir les euh les
les les monter si vous voulez et on a
publié beaucoup de livres quand vous
avez récupéré ces papiers que vous avez
fait réassembler par les petites mains
de femmes qui font des tapis vous avez
vu non ce sont des étudiants qui ont
fait nous n nous n'étions rien à
l'époque donc le gouvernement était rien
à l'époque c'était les étudiants à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade qui ont
vraiment constitué et monté tout ça et
les femmes qui font le tapis
elles font le
tapis pour vivre
dignement pour gagner leur vie avec une
une commentur de combien vous gagnez
vous je ne gagne rien oui je je
travaille
par c'est un secret c'est un secret
secret professionnel pourquoi
euh parce que je peux vous dire
n'importe
quoi j'espère pas non je ve dis c'est
pourquoi je ne veux j'hésite de vous
dire sinon je vous dirais
oui c'est en euros ou en
dollars comment c'est en euros ou en
dollars non en euro il y a longtemps
qu'on a changé
notre notre monnaie alors de choses déjà
déjà grâce à vous grâce à l'Iran on a pu
anticiper la guerre avec les Russes
parce que les Russes sétaient inspirés
de de de vous je pense pour contourner
Swift avoir un système différent et les
Russes se sont inspiré je pense de vos
manœuvres pour pouvoir survivre aux
sanctions ou anticiper les sanctions
donc merci à l'Iran de de ce travail qui
nous a permis en fait d'anticiper la
tension avec les Russes je vais vous
poser une question internet mais avant
ça je vais vous poser une question
personnelle la question internet je vous
laisse le temps d'y réfléchir c'est
quels seraient les plans de l'Iran pour
stabiliser le monde ça c'est la question
internet ma question c'est pas une
question laissz un par un parce que j'ai
un mémoire assez court vous êtes
ambassadeur non parce que je pour que je
puisse vous répondre on va faire une
expérience de pensée vous et moi je vous
en prie je voudrais que vous défendiez
Israël pendant 2
minutes
euh d'abord sur la première
question vous m'avez demandé qui est le
qu'est-ce qui est le plan d'Iran pour la
paix dans le monde quels seraient les
plans de l'Iran pour stabiliser le monde
oui c'est ce que je vous
dis l'Iran c'est un pays un petit
pays avec une population un niveau de
de je ne sais pas de l'armement de de de
force défensiv vous ça très petite si
vous comparez avec les autres pays dans
la région mais surtout hors de la région
donc pour nous
euh la stabilité
mondiale
passe
par une un effort
collectif par tous les pays mais au
premier plan ceux qui sont
mandatés pour sauvegarder la paix et la
stabilité au monde dans le monde qui est
mandaté euh je vous ai dit je vous ai
dit les membres permanents de du
Conseil Nations Unies et puis les
efforts de chacun des pays membres de
cette organisation partout dans le monde
donc l'Iran n'a pas une intention de
de de faire un travail à l'échelle
mondiale sur la paix tout
ça la deuxième question vous allez poser
à à celui que vous êtes vous avez dit
vous avez dit vous avez demandé de on on
a proposé la même interview à
l'ambassade d'Israël donc vous allez
demander là et on va lui demander de
défendre l'Iran pendant 2 minutes oui
vous pouvez lui demander mais mais je
préfère ne pas entrer
dans dans l'affaire de défendre parce
queouve-moi à mon avis ce n'est pas
défendable donc c'est is qui pas
défendable ou c'est le gouvernement
nataniaahou non vous
voyez vous voyez on peut toujours
relativiser les choses on peut
toujours prendre des options pour un
peu si vous voulais je n'accuse personne
je ne vise personne mais pour
relativiser la
tragédie qui est qui s'était passée dans
notre région durant tous ces ans
76 ans maintenant
et un peuple qui a été privé de cette
dignité
de de son de son
identité et
quand vous dites Israël ou ça c'est à
vous de juger et c'est à votre
interlocuteur celui qui vous écoute
c'est
irréconciliableir comment c'est
irréconciliable entre vous Israël Iran
c'est
irréconciliable si je vous propose vous
voyez non non non si je vous propose je
vous dis bon j'ai eu les Israéliens au
téléphone ils sont d'accord pour faire
une interview avec vous sur le le même
plateau vous acceptez vous acceptez pas
qui sont les Israéliens l'ambassadeur
d'Israël en France non non non non parce
que nous ne connaissons pas l'Israël
vous voyez il y a des pays qui qui ne se
reconnaissent pas nous ne reconnaissons
pas l'Israël
donc parce que nous pensons que l'Israël
c'est une création
et surtout
la tant que la
palestinienne le la patrie était pour
eux le territoire était
plus quand il y a eu la déclaration de
Balfour il y a eu 10 10 % des Juifs de
la population de ce territoire
occupé donc
90 % était Palestiniens et ils sont
où c'est là
que la justice
et l'équité
réside sin n parler avec quelqu'un sur
le plateau on ne pas parler reconnaître
ne pas
reconnaître l'important c'est que cette
justice soit établie après ça la région
aura une occasion pour s'épir si vous
voulez quelle puissance
vous
voyez permettant de réchauffer le
dialogue d'améliorer les choses qui
pourrait être médiateur entre tout ça
les Turcs les Russes les Américains les
français bien sûr que les amric les
Belges les portugis bien sûr que les
Américains parce que parce qu'ils sont
un
soutien euh bon
total malgré la vie des autres malgré la
vraiment
la la misère qui règne dans notre
région et puis ce n'est pas normal au
21e siècle chaque fois que vous décidez
vous tirez des missiles ici et là dans
dans tous les dans toutes les si vous
voulez parties de la
région et puis est-ce que c'est au
profit de la de la région au profit du
peuple est qui ne s'alimente pas les
extrémistes que ce soit religieux ou non
religieux les terroristes de de prendre
refuge derrière des des choses et des
principes sacrets et de de penser
pouvoir un peu attirer de de profit ici
et là notre région a souffert beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
et nous sommes des peuples parmi les
plus
souffer du monde donc il faut que le
peuple de la région ait une occasion
pour un développement pour un
épanouissement pour un une joie si vous
voulez mais mais ce n'est pas le cas il
faut il faut une rectification ce qui
partout dans le monde peut aider
n'importe quel pays que ça soit la ruses
les européens ou les asord comment Jord
n'importe quel pays doit contribuer à ce
que cette injustice prenne FA et après
ça vous AZ vous aurez voir que les
juifes les chrétiens les
musulmans seront heureux l'un à côté de
l'autre comme nous nous avons montré
l'Iran estant un sauveur des des Juifs à
l'époque estant un refuge pour les
Arméniens pour les chrétiens et même
aujourd'hui en Iran prenons l'exemple de
l'Iran le le pays le plus peuplé de
juives hors des territoires occupés
c'est l'Iran il n'y a pas eu d'exode il
n''y a pas eu de je ne sais pas program
qu'est-ce qu'on dit mais il n'y a pas eu
il y a un respect total à l'OM en Iran
que ça soit les chrétiens que ça soit le
le juif et les autres que ce soit les
étrangers
donc c'est un exemple vous voulez
trouver un exemple c'est l'Iran
l'exemple faisons la
région comme un Liu pour
coexistance Pacifique amicale fraternel
pour tous les croyants ou non croyants
c'est et la bière comment et la bière
c'est voyez dans la région peut-être un
jour vous avez déjà été à Dubaï à Dubaï
oui oui quelque fois oui à Dubaï oui je
suis avec mes amis dubaïotes oui très
pieux je suis en train de boire ma bière
l'heure de la prière mes amis Dubot vont
faire la
prière je continue à boire ma bière ils
reviennent et on continue la Pérou B eux
ils boivent pas de bière mais je peux
boire la bière est-ce qu'un jour ce sera
possible en Iran
l'Iran je vous laisse réflé voez non non
non je vous dis quelque chose même si
vous vous buvez
ici je ne vous interdis pas monsieur
encore heure on est en France non non
non non vous voyez je vous dis quelque
chose mon pays et mon peuple a des
spécificités propres à eux et les lois
qui règnent en
Iran les Émirats ont leur loi qui est
respectable et nous respectons comme un
voisin comme un pays et n'importe où
dans le pays que ça soit en Afrique que
ça soit ailleurs donc c'est c'est normal
si on souhaite nous nous ne souhaitons
pas nous
avons beaucoup de
défis essentiel pour notre développement
pour l'épanouissement que la question de
bière est n'est même pas visible dans le
horizon
de comment vous voyez le fait que la
population palestinienne de la bande de
Gaza certains diplomates certains pays
disent il faut la placé un pays disent
mais certains pays certains diplomates
je n'ai pas entendu est-ce qu'il y a des
réfugiés palestiniens chez vous chez
nous s'il y a pas important mais je ne
crois pas parce que normalement ils sont
arabes et ils préfèrent vivre dans les
pays arabes nous nous sommes pers et
nous notre langage notre tradition est
un peu différent je ne sais je ne dis
pas lequel est meilleur mais ou ou mieux
mais pour nous c'est toujours un honneur
de d'accueillir les les Palestiniens et
les Arabes dans notre pays il faut un
visa pour venir en tant que Français il
faut un visa pour aller en Iran bien sûr
bien sûr qu'il y a on peut le prendre à
l'aéroport ou il faut le prendre avant
non il faut il faut venir à l'ambassade
je crois à l'aéroport aussi c'est
possible s'il y a une coordination je
crois avec des agences de
touriste iranien Mo moi si je veux aller
faire un reportage en Iran pour aller
voir de mes propres yeux oui pour aller
discuter avec tout le monde h que ce
soit les pros les antis les pas antis
ceux qui boivent de la bière ou pas il
me faut quoi comme visa il faut que vous
nous avons des des réglementation très
précise là-dessus si vous êtes l'homme
de presse il faut qu'on a une
coordination préalable après ça si vous
recevez un visa vous partirez en Iran
vous ferez tout ce que vous avez annoncé
de faire
et vous allez être libre de si vous êtes
l'homme de presse si vous êtes touruse
vous pouvez aller n'importe où vous vlez
alors nous nous on est une chaîne
Youtube oui on on refuse la carte de
presse on paye la TVA à plein pot et on
n pas de syndicat de presse derrière
nous si moi je veux aller faire un
report il me faut un une carte de presse
ou pas non pas du tout mais vous devez
dire que vous êtes faire un métier de
presse en Iran est-ce que je vais être
suivi comment est-ce que je vais être
suivi je sais pas vous devez être suivi
ou pas si vous ne faites pas la bêtse
pourquoi vous vous vous posez une une
une hypothèse que N on est intenable
comment on est intenable ça veut dire ça
veut dire que on arrive et on va
discuter avec tout le monde et on rentre
partout ser à tout le monde essayez
après on va voir ce qui va se passer non
non non non non non vraiment je vous dis
je vous dis vous vous êtes en train de
faire la menace que si je vais je fais
je mais essayez essayez je je vous
décris on est jeune on aime discuter
avec tout le monde allez discuter avec
tout le monde vous aurez le temps de
discuter avec tout le monde est-ce que
si je veux visiter vos prisons il faut
que je demande à quelqu'un bien sûr
qu'il y a qu'il y a un sinon la prison
n'est pas une une place où chacun peut
aller visiter si vous connaissez un pays
où on a on peut aller visiter une prison
sans autorisation montrez-nous on va on
va essayer de nous assimiler à ça à qui
je dois demander pour aller visiter une
prison iranienne ou des prisons
iraniennes c'est normal il y a il y a
des
responsables quand vous allez en Iran
d'ici même en vous demandez que vous
voulez faire ça si on accepte vous
pouvez visiter si on on naccepte pas
vous ne pouvez pas visiter ce qui est
normal partout dans le monde pourquoi
vous avez fait des infrastructures
planquées sous la terre à 100 200 300 m
de
profondeur vous voyez stratégie
défensive des pays
varie donc chaque pays
choisit la meilleure méthode pour
pouvoir en cas de besoin de se défendre
c'est c'est ça que génie iranienne nous
a mené à avoir des capacités défensives
qui garantissent la sécurité la vie des
iranien et des intérêts supérieurs de
l'Iran notre pays cher c'est vous êtes
inspiré de la stratégie
Suisse ça peut être même question
internet qu'est-ce que l'Iran cherche ou
espère obtenir dans la négociation pour
la libération des otages
français des prisonniers français pour
vous si vous voulez oui je comprends
bien vous
voyez pour les
prisonniers
l'Iran c'est un
pays où
la loi
règne et on est un pays
responsable nous ne sommes pas
des des groupes qui cherchent
à euh apprendre des autres et puis en
contrepartie de pouvoir recevoir quelque
chose donc on a
montré pendant toutes ces années et
pendant tous ces
siècles
donc pour le gouvernement
iranien euh il n'y a pas une
contrepartie revendiquée pour n'importe
quel bien ou euh individus étrangers à
l'intérieur du pays question Internet
est-ce que l'Iran est proc
crypto pour contourner le dollar
l'Iran n'a pas besoin de d'abord
l'économie iranienne est tellement
grande que qu'avec le crypto il il peut
pas
euh d'abord en effet
de de contourner de prendre crypto pour
contourner le dollar d'ailleurs le
dollar n'est pas notre devise étrangère
euh préféré et utilisé si vous voulez et
nous les gens les Iraniens sont
tellement
intelligents de pouvoir entrer dans le
dans le monde
crypto mais pas le gouvernement qui a
des des fonctions et des
devoirs différents question internet
quel est son poème préféré de
aphèz de hafèz de haèz H a F e oui oui
oui c'est c'est un poète très célèbre
iranien non le le livre de haz est
tellement riche qu'on peut que chacun
peut vraiment choisir euh le poème ou la
la partie qu'elle aime bien que tout
c'est enrichissante
euh euh mais il y en a il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup même
parce qu'on s'est habitué de l'enfance
par les bouquins de de l'école de de de
lire
haz lez et est utilisé chez les Iraniens
parfois comme
euh pas comparable mais comme le Coran
pour demander la vie
deè en ce qui concerne le souhait ou la
question qu'on en a donc
une
partie
de juste au début qui disent que
l'amour fait simple au
début mais après il y a les
difficultés on est à peu près le même en
France c'est vrai
ouacord question internet la peine de
l'aposta Estelle appliqué conformément à
la charien en Iran entre parenthèses
peine de
mort non ce n'est pas ce n'est pas en
application parce qu'il y a vous voyez
beaucoup de commentaires pour être
aposta qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
àosttin donc vous ne voyez pas des des
exemples dans dans le passé ou quelqu'un
est euh est mort ou est é pendu
a subi la peine de mort pour aposta
c'est très vous voyez c'est c'est une
com c'est un commentaire très
varié c'est une prétention qui n'a pas
eu lieu en question internet dans le
chapelet mahoméan Dieu à 99 Noms entre
parenthèses par exemple Raman le
Miséricordieux lequel est vot votre
préférence pour
moi
c'est
brahmanahim question Internet vous avez
fini votre réponse oui question internet
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur adhérez-vous à
l'idée que les conflits politiques sont
avant tout un affrontement des modèles
familiaux entre parenthèses tel que la
l'avancé
Emmanuel
Tod tel que la avancé Emmanuel Tod la la
question politique Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur adhérez-vous à l'idée que
les conflits politiques sont avant tout
un affrontement des modèles familiaux
non je n'ai pas aucune idée question
internet comment vous voyez l'arrivée de
Trump au
pouvoir nous
voyez euh le président Trump est un élu
des Américains pour les affaires
américaines
pour
la pour
le la gestion des affaires
américaines nous les Iraniens nous
avons pu avoir une occasion de 4 ans
Monsieur Trump comme le président de la
République s'il est bien pour les
Américains tant mieux pour les
Américains pour les autres peuples
nation nous espérons que son av
son pouvoir 2e
mandat soit euh un élément
supplémentaire pour la paix et la
sécurité et une justice internationale
et une justice relative dans les
affaires internationales parce que c'est
vrai les états est un grand
pays et donc de ce grand pays tout le
monde attend un comportement digne
à de grands pays et ça va ça va se
passer par vous avez eu l'IRAC l'IRAC
c'était digne comment l'Irak oui
l'intervention américaine en Irak
c'était digne non je ne dis pas cétait
digne non non non je je je souhaite
c'est le souhait des autres pays que je
vous parle que que le comportement de
chaque pays même des Iraniens même soit
dans la dans le cadre
où un élément supplémentaire pour la
paix et la
sécurité internationale et la dignité
des nations du monde entier
et donc une coopération
euh multilatérale parce que nous nous
nous sommes des partisans des
multilatéralismes soit établis sans des
tendances individuel ou d'un pays on
fait une expérience de pensé vous et moi
une autre oui
imaginez-vous on
a notre
notre on a on a
notre NASA ou notre bureau spatial qui
voit un météorite une
météorite en trajectoire pour
s'effondrer sur
Israël et on a 2 semaines avant que ça
tombe sur Israël attendez attendez
attendez est-ce que vous accueillez la
population israélienne chez vous pour
les protéger de la météorite vous voyez
la population non je n'ai pas compris le
non non non non je vous dis le sens je
vous dis si si je me trompe vous après
vous m'expliquez vous
voyez les
Israéliens sont composés des Juifs des
musulmans des chrétiens
et des autres et
sont la création de Dieu comme tous les
individus partout dans le monde
donc si
euh dans un pays quelconque
euh le comportement des dirigeants ne
sont pas à la
hauteur de la de la responsabilité et de
la dignité du peuple ce n'est pas la
faute
nécessairement des
populations les Juifs une partie des
Juifs israéliens sont partis de l'Iran
même si SS ne sont pas très nombreux
mais ceux qui sont
là parmi eux il y a des des sens
vraiment humains à l'envers des autres
individus dans le dans dans l'Israël et
ailleurs c'est avec grand
volontier qu'on va accueillir n'importe
quel
peuple sous les souffrances à
l'intérieur de notre pays et c'est un
devoir
national historique
religieuse question internet quelle est
la position de l'Iran par rapport au
conflit autour de ses frontières Arménie
azerbaïjan euh vous savez nous dans les
régions nous avons comme une famille
surtout que la l'histoire des Iraniens
des Arméniens et des aériens ont
beaucoup de
communalité et la culture je ne veux pas
euh faire la
référence à
l'histoire mais pour le moment pour
l'état actuel des
choses ils sont notre ns
voisins tous ces
payslà pour
nous le peup de tous ces pays sont comme
notre peuple avec qui nous nous vivons
les
jours triste que les jours en joie et
donc notre regard n'est pas un regard
de d'intervention
ise ou suprémaciste non par contre un
regard
responsable pour pouvoir
contribuer dans une coopération légale
avec leur gouvernement de faire en sorte
que la paix et la stabilité puisse être
la la premier le premier choix et la le
choix préférent
préférentiel pour les habitants de tous
les pays que dans ce cas-là nous les
Iraniens aussi nous allons vraiment euh
être ravi et heureux donc voilà c'est
c'est on arrive bientôt à à la fin de
notre interview je voudrais que vous me
donniez trois défauts trois qualités des
Français vous voyez che euh
personnellement
personnellement euh j'ai
commencé dans ma jeunesse un peu euh
dans un métier de pas justice mais lié à
la
justice très peu mais dans
les dans les affaires pas très sérieux
si vous voulez
et après je n'ai jamais souhaité de
juger les autres
en tout cas ce n'est pas ma
préférence vous voyez
donc vous n'avez pas trois
qualités le peuple français a de
multiples
qualités positif je ne rigole pas je
n'exagère pas alors TR qualités à chaque
à chaque nation il y a des des richesses
qu'il faut qu'il faut apprécier qu'il
faut accepter et mais si nécessaire
applaudir mais chaque nation a aussi des
défaillances tris qualifi trois défauts
des
Iraniens nous sommes très
bon la première ensuite non c'est bon
c'est bon c'est suffisant c'est bon
c'est suffisantok non vraiment les
Iraniens sont sont très tolérant très
accueillant et très aimant les autres
vraiment
et avec la conviction qu'ils doivent
maîtriser les meilleurs du monde et
c'est pourquoi nos jeunes nos fils quand
il ne voi pas la possibilité vraiment de
se de s'épanuir ils prennent la route de
l'immigration he l'immigration vous
dites et où ils sont ils sont des hommes
euh et des femmes euh euh complètement
réussi euh et nous sommes nous avons des
vraiment d'une d'une d'une communauté de
qualités partout dans le monde euh c'est
ce sont des qualités que je peux vous
dire vraiment
c'est en ce qui concerne les Iraniens
mon cher
compatriote ch compatriotes est-ce qu'il
y a un sujet que vous aimeriez aborder
avec nous qu'on n pas
abordé euh
euh non
vraiment je crois que vous avez bien
fait en faire un tour d'horizon dans les
sujets intéressants importants pourquoi
vous avez accepté de venir chez
nous et qu'est-ce que vous avez vu qu'on
avait produit
déjà non j'ai vu quelques parties
de quelques complets mais quel quelques
partie des interviews
et et et cela après votre approche votre
euh contact avec euh mon secrétariat
j'ai essayé de voir ce que vous faites
et ce que vous demandez ce que vous et
j'ai vu que non vous vous donnez la rép
vous vous devez la le temps nécessaire à
votre hôte de pouvoir s'exprimer c'est
très important aujourd'hui ce que nous
manquons c'est
écouter nous
voulons dire et redire notre histoire et
notre notre analyse et notre point de
vue
et peu nous
sommes prêts à entendre la vie des
autres la la réalité de de la pensée des
autres et et puis le média a pris une
une place très importante mais le média
est très bonne quand il informe les
autres mais il est très mauvais quand il
essaie de de d'imposer une vision aux
autres ce qui normalement fait en sorte
que qu'une guerre une
crime devient un un
événement supportable et une tentative
de paix soit considérée comme une guerre
ou une une une une action
euh contre la la la la nature de l'homme
donc euh ce que vous avez donné à moi
cette occasion pour
m'exprimer pour contribuer à ce que la
voix de l'Iran puisse c'est ententre
et la situation de mon peuple mon grand
peuple puisse être vraiment senti hors
des des des voix qui sont
malheureusement parfois manipulées
parfois
organisé mais donc c'est c'est c'est
très important et donc c'est mon message
pour vous donc tout ce que vous faites
c'est ça que peut-être euh très
clairement vous n'avez pas aborder mais
j'ai senti je le répète et j'espère que
vous continuez et que par là vous vous
vous vous vos écouteurs puissent
vraiment
euh encore ajouter à leur savoir et la
liberté de la presse en
Iran bon vous voyez nous aussi comme je
vous ai dit nous avons une société avec
une une des spécificités qui sont à
nous mais si vous voulez bien nous avons
des chaînes de télévision des dizaines
des vingtaines de trentaines au moment
de la Révolution était deux deux une
partie politique de chaînes de
télévision mais il y a une quantité de
chaînes et chaînes privé aussi mais sur
l'Internet si vous voulez
et nous avons sur les médias des des
différents
station de radio si vous
voulez beaucoup de
publications journalière hebdomadaire
mensuel trimestriel
euh donc dans le cadre de vraiment de la
réglementation du pays et de la comme je
vous ai dit il y a une diversité de
moyen de de de se de s'éduquer de se de
s'informer mais vous aimez quoi comme
musique euh musique traditionnelle
j'aime très très très bien le
rap mais je ne sais pas de la de la
génération qui aime le rap mais je ne
connais même pas si vous voulez bien
parce que mon mon plaisir
est est la la musique classique des
grands euh iraniens euh morts ou envie
donc qui sont le nom vous voulez dire
oui mais vous savez
charian Nazeri euh
corbani euh il y en a il y en a il y en
a des des g en France en France là très
récemment on a vu un concert d'une
chanteuse iranienne sans son foulard oui
avec son pianiste avec son autre
musicien diffusé sur Internet oui
qu'est-ce qu' est devenue cette personne
là je ne connais pas je ne connais pas
et vous savez le nom parce que il y a
beaucoup beaucoup des iranien pianiste
acteur Activ dans à Dubaï en émirat en
Istanbul aux États-Unis en Europe mais
mais je ne sais pas lequel vous parle
maintenant
elle
s'appelle parastou
Amadi je ne connais pas mais ça doit
être quelqu'un libre dans le pays il est
il réside en Iran donc s'il y a
eu bon s'il y a eu quelques ennuis à
l'envers elle et son pianiste et son
pianiste et son compositeur et son
compositeur vous
verrez beaucoup d'en parler de le fait
qu'il qu'il a qu'il n'a pas eu le
foulard d'ailleurs en Iran aujourd'hui i
il y a il y a ça se voit dans les rues
des Iraniens qui ne portent pas des
foulards et le fait qu'il est bon il est
rentré en Iran et il vit normal ça veut
dire que qu'est-ce qui vous devait lui
arriver pour donner un encore un atour
est-ce que vous avez vu la série le
bureau des légendes de le bureau des
légendes non non série française avec
Matthieu Kassovitz non je non je n pas
même entendu qu'est-ce que vous avez vu
comme film cident qui parlait de l'Iran
est-ce que vous avez vu ce film où il y
a un réalisateur américain qui se fait
passer pour un un producteur de film
mais en fait c'est pas du tout un
producteur de film et qui voulait faire
sortir des des gens
ah au cours de la Révolution vous en
parlez juste après je pense juste après
oui des parties que j'ai vu quand
j'étais jeune
oui j'ai vu il y a de la censure sur
Internet en Iran non
il faut un VPN pour se il fallait il
fallait un VPN et cela dans la logique
d'empêcher que la tuerie et la révolte à
l'intérieur du pays ne soit pas
alimenté de l'étranger mais tout
récemment le gouvernement de de notre
actuel président de la République on
fait en sorte
que graduellement si vous voulez les
cette restriction soit levée dans la
première partie on a fait sur WhatsApp
et deux autres je crois ou trois autres
mais ça va continuer jusqu'à la
normalisation et je vous dis avant
c'estes ces
euh manifestation tout ça il y a 3 ans
il y a eu une une liberté totale sur
l'Internet il y a énormément de
questions de notre communauté je vous en
prends une au au hasard Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur pourrait-il nous parler
des relations ou espoir de relation avec
les pays voisins de l'Iran la Syrie
l'Arabie saoudite le
Qatar quel avenir souhaite-t-il pour les
nations pour la nation iranienne sur le
plan international quelles alliances
comment expliquez-vous que l'Iran soit
rempli de stupéfiant malgré la loi
islamique opium cannabis et aussi
beaucoup d'alcool de contrebande venu de
Dubaï il y en a plein il y en a plein
vous en prenez une derère il faut écrire
une livre un livre vous allez revenir
oui non c'est on vous propose de revenir
vous revenez on on peut on peut toujours
on discuter oui non non on peut venir
pourquoi pas avec une une distance de
temps un peu raisonnable euh est-ce que
vous avez trois livres à nous conseiller
à conseiller à notre communauté
euh je pense qu'un livre peut être
choisi un livre peut être choisi par le
choix individuelle sur la guerre Iran
Irak il y en a beaucoup de livres mais
ça monte beaucoup de choses je crois que
si on on trouve un livre un livre par
choix on peut savoir la racine de de la
situation peut-être
euh
quelconque
actuel
deuxièmement un livre qui est très
important et qui
peut expliquer la
la si vous voulez la nature du
comportement de et de de de l'approche
iranien qui est le livre de roi
ferdossier
euh qui a fait beaucoup sur la culture
et la civilisation iranienne
moderne sur la langue
iranienne même sur la les croyances
monothéistes des Iraniens
c'est le
2e le
3è encore par le choix pour trouver un
livre sur les événements juste après la
Révolution islamique en
Iran comme je vous ai dit les tentatives
de séparation dans les différentes
parties du du pays
une tuerie
aveugle des gens et des
innocents et puis après une guerre que
je vous ai dit un livre suffirait de
voir quel vraiment dans quel situation
de
de négative les
Iraniens se sont trouvés devant une une
une agression totale
toutimus et une autre un autre livre que
je peux vous dire vous donner vous vous
dire que l'écriture c'est très simple la
la lecture est simple mais beaucoup de
sagesse là-dedans c'est le un livre de
Sadi Golestan ça veut dire le quoi le
jardinage où il y a beaucoup de beaucoup
de sagesse et et
euh beaucoup de pureté de
la de l' sence de l'OM et des Iraniens
al vu qu'on parle de livre est-ce que
vous connaissez ou est-ce que vous avez
lu le livre nous n'avons pas peur de
Nathalie aMARIE et de douen
tcal
non est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer quelque chose d'impérissable
en fait je
peux je peux dire aux
jeunes ça veut dire c'est ce que je
préfère de dire à ma à mon à mes
fils que
qu'essayer il va mieux
d'essayer d'être toujours
dans une situation informer des
choses et de de prendre parti dans le
côté où il y a la justice et où il y
a de la
pureté donc pour le reste la vie vous
vous mènera vers les
objectifs
assez
précieuse Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Mohamed
aminejad merci merci à vous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]